Yeah, I make Youtube videos.
Laugh at other people's memes and get money
*look at his eyes. They tell stories of the old Viking battles*
Joke's on you, I don't make any money!
cuz the videos get monite- demone- nah
*ayy intensifies*
ay mane(n) ay
*ayy intensifies continues*
aey
What up you poor people?
Check out my latest car that I bought!
(on this free image Brad cut into this green screen? nice)
That's right, pretty impressive, I know. What's that in the back?
*ding* Oh, that's my mansion, that you could never afford
(unless i download it haha yes)
That's right, I am so incredibly rich!
Just kidding! Haha! You fell for that old meme?
(no, who the heck would even fall for that)
This is a green screen. (but it's white. like u)
*double pewds*
You can do all kinds of things with these
Hey, look now, I'm... in uhm...
*pewds realizes where is he now in 3*
*pewds realizes where is he now in 2*
*pewds realizes where is he now in 1*
I'm in India now...
(nice teleportation skills)
Just kidding
Hey, look.
Now, I'm in Guatemala
Just kidding
*questions his life choices that led him to this moment*
This green screen is from Elgato.
I'm gonna link them in the description
if you guys want to check them out. This thing is genius!
If you ever had a green screen, it is the ugliest- it looks amazing on videos
Like it can really- it can really amp up the quality of your content and really put yourself out there
But if you ever use the green screen
it takes up your entire space,
it looks ugly,
it's wonky as hell.
A lot of them are just cheap and bad
You need to light it properly
so you need to get all this lighting equipment
With this baby,
I'm saying this from the bottom of my heart.
I mean- never been some more genuine-
Never been more genuine about a promo
(welcome to hell army of 9 year olds)
This makes my life so much easier.
You know I- how I had that projector and the-
like before I had this giant bar on my ceiling and that was a
projector that I just painted green.
And I paid more for that than this Elgato thing
So yeah, if you make videos check out Elgato
Obviously,
#Spons
But also very nice
"Now move on with the video Felix, please."
"Can you stop selling us things?"
"You literally just made fun of us for being poor."
You're right
Leave your memes in the comments below
and I'll pick my favorites
in the next episode of
YIAY
What MEMES did you submit this week?
Oh~
I can't wait!
The real reason why Sweden lost last night
Posted five days ago
Sweden lost because Germany played well
Pff! No.
Sweden lost because they played badly
Pff!
No!
No, Sweden lost because they didn't worship Zlatan before the match
Pff!
NO
Sweden lost because Pewdiepie didn't include me- Bonus Meme in the latest  *trips over his words*
Bonus meme is dead.
Jesus Christ
Way to rub it in
Haha
Good Roasts
WALLLLMART!
The Paul brothers
When the fight breaks down in UK('s)  KSI
I just start yelling
PRIIIIMARK
Upvote for Pewds to react to another country
HMmmm
I was gonna do a Swedish one, but
just so it doesn't seem like I'm just hating on all these countries
but there's nothing funny about Sweden they just-
It's just in jokes that are unfunny.
Thank you bus driver, very cool.
Thank you *clap clap* *meme dies*
Well done!
You know, say what you want about Trump
But at least
he thanks the bus driver
Upvote if you want Pewds to ACTUALLY show his YouTube analytics
To see how many nine year olds actually in the army.
Okay. Well, let's just have a... As you can see here
They're all 9 year olds.
The 13 year olds had the- have the lowest attention span
(get gud kids! YEETn't)
select all squares
containing a dishwasher
*clap clap* *Meme: Felix, I don't feel so good*
Oh
The jokes around the sexist
I've seen this one it's the- it's clearly the best Loss
Ooga Booga-booga sleepy sleepy
She's asleep now
Thank you for coming here, hypnosis.
Hypnosis?
Hypnotist
Which way is the exit?
-It's right over there.
Okay guy- okay. Bye guys I'm leaving
A Lost in another universe
Very nice.
This is the fan art I get?
(Why are we here?)
(Just to suffer)
What the hell is that? It's like a hedgehog on my face
it's not even accurate
Women reveal two words they LOVE hearing during sex
Meme *clap* Revie- *clap*
Goddammit
HahahahaHA
Fock the pauls fam. Fock the p-
WAAAALLLLMAARTT
Coca-cola
he stole your health
Disney
he stole your childhood
Prawn hub
he stole your innocent (innocence)
Pewdiepie
he stole your cont- NO
I'm giving YOU content
It's different. Definitely
Last night, someone edited our Wikipedia page
to say he was our family. Showed security at our show,
got into the green room and had a beer with the boys
Spargo, you legend
Thanks for the evening, lads.
What an absolute mad lad, everybody.
Slow internet again
Either my son is downloading prawn
or my daughter is uploading it
*laugh track plays in the background*
*soullessly smiles at the camera*
This meme makes sense because...
it's how it makes me laugh
Really funny *laugh track continues*
Oh... *cringes*
It's all upvote. It's all upvote
IT'S ALL UPVOTE
Well, this 7 year old video of Pewds has showed up in my recomanded (wrong spelling)
I guess you guys are really are 9
Congratulations
That has 8 million views?
That's crazy
Fridays with Pewdipi-
LEAVE YOUR ENTRIES IN THE SUBREDDIT BROS
AND I'LL WATCH SUBMISSIONS IN THE NEXT EPISODE OF
LWIAY
*amused laugh*
Well done, good meme.
That was awesome, Vooltex Foda.
Faith restored in this subreddit.
Well done!
Yeah, I make Youtube videos
Laugh at other people's memes and get money
*speechless*
Joke's on you.
I don't make any money
cuz the videos get monite- demone- nah
Upvo- NOooooOOO
Upvote- *bleep*
Accepting that the new EU regulations ban memes
Adding an overlay so the filter won't detect it
I mean literally-
me and Brad have been doing this for years
Whenever we have to use audio, we pitched it
so he doesn't get detected
or we'll try and use it a little shorter
before it was like a 15-second thing.
This is literally it
This is how- what we're already living this meme.
This is not a meme. It's life
(truer words have never been spoken)
*silent laugh*
Honestly
so *bleep*
(to himself) Can I stop swearing, please?
As- Dear Pewds *cue emotional piano track*
as a devoted fan base we can't help but notice
You've been acting very stressed in recent videos
I think I speak on behalf of the 9 year old army when I say,
Suck it up, you whiny little b-
*cue 9 year old army sound track*
No one gives an F about you and your... depression
*resume sad piano track*
I've never been more proud.
Finally
you guys understand
Finally,
I have an audience...
that's not a bunch of little *bleep*
Spend hours making these birds talk
*birds sings Blend S opening*
*cuts track*
SKRATTTA DU?!
FORLORAR DU!!
MANEN! (the Remix)
Holy hell. The edit *genuinely impressed*
*pitched explosion*
Fake. Its fake. Okay
It's not cringey if it's fake.
Don't waste my time with this.
*snort-ish laugh*
Damn
You're (got) some solid edits in here.
s(uh)m(a)j(a)135
A well done
Nihon-go, namaste. (Japanese language, hello)
Pewds,
They're still going have some mercy
The thing is the more this goes on,
the more inevitable it's going to be the fact that I'll have to eat hi-
*clap clap*
r/wooosh on Pewdiepie submissions
92% won't get this joke
Are you the nine percent?
Apparently Math isn't your strongest suit?
This is clearly a whooosh-ception
Like the bird said,
"I can't cringe if it's fake. Don't waste my time"
Whoever's doing the caption is killing me
Realizes he couldn't come up with a joke in time because he's not creative
and that he gets all his comedic credit
from his fans and editors.
Hey,
you know- that is
So this is the EU flag.
Yup
And you know, it's public domain
So making it a meme won't actually change anything
That makes sense
So stop making those memes
On July 5th, we must only upvote pictures of the
EU flag
so they become a meme and
must ban themselves.
Upvote-
OH MY GOD! This is genius!
Finally, we'll fight fire with fire.
*US national anthem plays*
There will be no banning on memes
on my command
That's right.
My- can we get some military audio?
My fellow 9 year olds,
On July 5th
We will strike them
at dawn.
We will fight them
with their own weapons of machinery.
Copyri- copy strikes
That's right. Copy Strikes
EU flags. Blasted
Upvote this video
if you want another
LWIAY